dans des soirées les global quand on est
obligé d'interrompre comme ça nos
invités mais c'est la règle je vous la
connaissez valérie pécresse mes chers
compatriotes
dans cette campagne j'ai porté
l'ambition d'une france unie libre et
fière je voulais vous convaincre que le
courage de mener une vraie politique de
droite autour des valeurs d'autorité de
liberté et de travail était la solution
pour redonner à notre pays la force et
la prospérité qu'ils méritent et aux
françaises et aux français une vie
meilleure
j'ai dû batailler sur deux fronts contre
le camp du président sortant et contre
celui des extrêmes allié en la
circonstance pour diviser et battre la
droite républicaine
malgré la passion qui m'anime malgré la
qualité notre projet je n'ai pas réussi
dans cette campagne atrophiée et en
l'absence de vrais débats à me délivrer
de cet étau et à vous convaincre
ce soir le réflexe du vote utile a joué
à plein et le peuple de france a voté et
son verdict s'impose à nous
ce résultat est évidemment une déception
personnelle et collective
j'assume en responsabilité toute ma part
dans cette défaite
à toutes celles et tous ceux qui m'ont
fait l'honneur de leur vote dans
l'hexagone outre mer et à l'étranger je
veux leur dire ma reconnaissance
et que leur soutien est à jamais gravée
dans mon coeur je veux également
remercier l'équipe exceptionnelle de
fidélité et d'engagement qui s'est
démultiplié partout sur le territoire
pour porter haut nos convictions et nos
couleurs je reste persuadé que notre
projet courageux et réformateurs et le
bon pour la france et pour nos
compatriotes
après un quinquennat de crise
d'immobilisme et de louvoiement il faut
remettre de l'ordre dans le pays et il y
attend à reconstruire voilà pourquoi la
droite et le centre
solidement enracinée dans les
territoires ne doivent rien lâcher ne
pas se diviser ne pas renoncer à leur
valeur est mené avec détermination le
combat des législatives qui s'annoncent
le second tour de l'élection
présidentielle opposera donc à nouveau
emmanuel macron et marine le pen ce soir
je suis profondément inquiète pour
l'avenir de notre pays alors que
l'extrême droite n'a jamais été aussi
près de l'emporter
en épargnant au premier tour les
extrêmes et en esquivant le débat
démocratique emmanuel macron a joué avec
le feu et fait prendre un énorme risque
à la france nous pourrions tous en payer
le prix
vous le savez j'ai construit mon
engagement politique contre les extrêmes
de droite comme de gauche je les ai
toujours combattue avec force et
constance car je crois comme jacques
chirac que tout dans l'âme de la france
dit non à l'extrémisme
le projet de marine le pen conduirait le
pays à la discorde à l'impuissance et à
la faillite sa proximité historique avec
vladimir poutine la discrédite pour
défendre les intérêts de notre pays dans
l'étang tragique que nous vivons son
élection on dirait à l'effacement de la
france sur les scènes européennes et
internationales
ainsi et malgré les profondes
divergences que j'ai martelé tout au
long de la campagne je voterai en
conscience emmanuel macron pour empêcher
l'arrivée au pouvoir de marine le pen et
le chaos qui en résulterait je les dis
[Applaudissements]
je les dis je ne suis pas propriétaire
des suffrages qui se sont portés sur mon
nom mais je demande 12 et aux électrices
et aux électeurs qui m'ont honoré de
leur confiance de peser dans les jours
qui viennent avec gravité les
conséquences potentiellement
désastreuses pour notre pays et pour les
générations futures de tout choix
différent du mien qu'il envisagerait
pour le second tour
à l'issue de ces mois ci intense de
rencontre de dialogue dans les villes et
les villages qui font la beauté la
diversité et l'identité de notre pays je
veux enfin dire aux françaises et aux
français que je les aime passionnément
que mon engagement politique est intact
et que pour améliorer leur quotidien et
leur destin je mènerai d'autres combats
je continuerai à me battre de toutes mes
forces pour vous servir et défendre une
certaine idée de la france vive la
république et vive la france
[Applaudissements]
voilà valérie pécresse qui vient de
prendre la parole et serait
[Musique]